hold on to your lettuce and put on your
finest clothes now Hut that one because
we have the latest episode of watchmen
and thinks story is here to break it all
down so let's not waste any of your time
and get right into it we begin in World
War one Germany where a typist by the
name of Fraulein Muller is called to
dictate a propaganda flyer for a German
commander keep a mental note of that
last name as it will come into play
later on in the episode she's typing up
the same flyer we saw the father right
watch over this boy on in episode 1 the
flyer itself is a scathing portrayal of
how African American soldiers were
treated at home and offers these
soldiers help if they were to defect
it's based off real flyers that the
Germans drop to destroy the morale of
African American troops
I'm just glad none of them left because
World War two would have really sucked
here we see a German plane tossing the
Flyers over the all African American
company and the father from Episode one
who now has a name on IMDB as Obie
Williams picking one up so this event
here takes place between 1917 and 1918
three years before the Tulsa massacre of
1921 for whatever reason Obie has
decided to hang on to this piece of
paper this link between Germany and the
United States will likely deepen as the
show goes on since both dr. Manhattan
and Ozymandias parents emigrated to the
u.s. from Germany the little boy from
episode 1 tries on his father's uniform
and finds the flyer as we transition to
the same man now roughly 100 years later
he's still holding on to that flyer
which shows signs of aids just like
himself we're picking up right at the
end of episode 1 with the arrival of
Angela having seen Judd hung by the tree
but how did this man possibly lift a
body over 200 pounds you think I can
lift 200 pounds Angela brings will our
wheelchair man to the back of her bakery
where she cuffs him and transforms into
sister Knight giving herself a moment to
vent about the death of her friend Judd
she finds a bottle of pills and the
flyer on him now I can't help but notice
his purple vest a very intriguing color
choice considering we saw Ozymandias
last episode wear purple and also
receive a purple cake I can't help but
think there's a connection between these
two characters if you watch my episode 1
breakdown i theorize that time travel or
travelling between dimensions will
likely play a role in this series and i
think we'll hear is somehow able to do
this perhaps it was a younger version of
himself who killed juds so he wouldn't
be lying when he said he was the one to
string him up he also talks about these
pills which he says are for his memory
and that it's been a long time since
he's been home when he's referring to a
long time I think he could quite
literally be meaning the word time he
tells Angela that there is a vast
conspiracy that Judd was involved with
and that he'll give her parts of it
piece by piece
her pager goes off and she calls the
number to find out what she already
knows that Judd is dead she takes with
her wills coffee mug to hold on as DNA
evidence in the early morning at the
newspaper stand yes there is no internet
in this world most people still get
their news from papers we get a bunch of
little snippets of information about
what's going on in the world the sign
here mentions squids drop on four cities
like we saw happen in Tulsa in episode
one and the delivery man suggests
interdimensional 'ti as the cause as I
suggested in Episode one the squid
probably have something to do with the
giant interdimensional squid Ozymandias
unleashed in New York and later blamed
dr. Manhattan for we see a copy of the
new frontiersman a far-right leaning
publication and the Tulsa Sun which
announces Keynes running for president
in an attempt to oust president Redford
we heard about this last episode over
the radio before Judd meets his untimely
demise
this is Senator Joe Keene son Joe jr.
whose father was the one who tabled the
infamous Keene Act which banned costumed
crime fighters saved those sanctioned by
the government were then introduced to
this character named PN the newspaper
man says that there won't be any Nova
Express until the afternoon Nova Express
is basically a rival to the new
frontiersman critical of costume
adventurers as well it is thought that
Nova Express was bankrolled by one of
oz' Man Diaz's companies and one of its
journalists Doug Roth was the first to
see a connection between
dr. Manhattan and his co-workers getting
cancer the N is picking up a bunch of
papers for a yet unknown character who
apparently reads all of them angela
arrives at the crime scene and is
informed by looking glass that Judds car
was found not too far away with its
tires blown the cause of his death it's
fiction but how could a 105 year old man
who can't even get himself into a car do
this also Looking Glass pulls up his
mass and eats nuts just like Rorschach
would pull up his and eat beans he even
begins to interrogate Angela about where
she was last night and takes a jab about
her kids not really being her own kids
but before we can get any further a
member of the paparazzi crash lands on
their car these journalistic scum are
known as moths but instead of being
drawn to a flame they're drawn to a news
story Red Scare smashes the moths camera
and ass Angela who's in charge with Judd
Gahan who will become the new head of
the Tulsa PD is still yet to be known we
flashback to christmas several years ago
where Calvin seems to have a present for
Angela you can tell by the small amount
of presents under the tree this is
before the a bars have taken in Topher
and the other kids into their home in
fact this is the white knight a knight
mentioned briefly in the last episode
where dozens of officers were
systematically killed in a coordinated
attack resulting in the adoption of the
Keene act and Angela's eventual
resignation forcing her to take her
crime-fighting ways underground what I
find most interesting about this scene
is that we never see how angela is saved
nor what happened to Judd who we see has
also survived the white knight and with
Angela later finding a Klan robe in
Judds house
there's definitely something larger at
play here it's here we learn that
Angela's partner Doyle and his wife were
killed in the attack leaving his three
children without a home this is how
Angela and cow come to take in Topher
and his sisters with Judd becoming a
uncle figure to them as Topher says to
Angela later on Judd isn't his real
uncle Jed also brings up the fact that
Angela rarely cries we also see this
when she finds Judd dead body instead of
crying she internalizes the pain and
unleashes it through violence like when
she beats the crap out of one of Nixon
Vil's residents believing the residents
of Nixon
have some sort of hand in Judds death
they raid the trailer park my guess is
that we'll see one of these residents in
the next episode in episode 1 we got a
brief mention of Redford Asians and here
outside the Greenwood Center for
cultural heritage we get a little bit
more info but what exactly these
reparations are when Angela approaches
one of these kiosks she's greeted by
Henry Louis Gates Jr who is a real-life
african-american scholar and professor
at Harvard University
in this universities now treasurer of
the United States and by giving a sample
of your DNA you can find out if you're
eligible for compensation under the
victims of racial violence Act the white
protestors outside don't see this as
fair their signs read equal rights
equals equal taxes and you got a sorry
now want a handout with many of the
white townspeople living in a trailer
park these reparations have caused
resentment and brought out deep-rooted
racism angela comes home to find this
man simply known as andy on her doorstep
demanding to see the kids by my best
guess this is a relative perhaps father
of Angela's former partner Doyle or his
wife he doesn't really care about seeing
the kids and as easily shoot away when
Angela offers him money Angela knows she
has to break the news to Topher that Jud
has passed notice the Magna Hatton
blocks he's playing with here which are
held afloat by the power of magnets a
magnet which will later see used to pick
up old will on his car notice also this
structure he's building the same one we
see dr. Manhattan create on Mars and one
which looks eerily similar to Ozymandias
castle Topher is allowed to watch
American hero story the big television
event advertised on planes and buses in
episode 1 and after the longest intro
warning I've ever seen juxtaposed to the
creation of a suicide vest by the
cavalry were given the introduction of
Ralf Muller his body washed ashore along
the boston river first rolf has this
same last name as the typist from the
introduction a circus strongman from
east germany he emigrated to the US and
joined the circus and it was believed
that he was a serial killer of children
implied in the narration Muller faked
his own death so he could become
something new hooded justice it was a
way for him to release all of his
pent-up rage much like
how Angela's sister night is her way to
take out her rage but more interesting
are the connections between Muller and
Judd notice how both men have one shoe
missing from their dead bodies
combine that with mother saying he faked
his own death could the same be said for
Judd later on in the episode Ozymandias
talks about how they could have a use
for Phillips corpse and earlier will
talks about dr. manhattan's ability to
change skin color and create clones of
himself we already know Ozymandias has
clones of his servants is it possible
that the Judd hanging from this tree
isn't Judd at all rather Judd or someone
else wanting us to think that he is we
get this flashback in 1938 focusing on
Orson Welles fake alien invasion radio
cast War of the Worlds
just like Rolf's body was a hoax so too
does this scene start with one before
introducing us to Ralph's alter-ego
hooded justice believed to be the first
masked Avenger and a charter member of
the Minutemen Angela brings roses over
to a mourning Jane who is a long sign
senator Joe King jr. Jane used to work
with Joe and there's this weird line Joe
says where he tells Angela that she can
have all the resources she needs to find
whoever did this to Judd insinuating
that he knows she's a crime fighter she
even has to reiterate that she's retired
Senator Joe is running in direct
opposition to president Redfern a man
seen as being very far left on the
political spectrum with Angela later
finding a Klan robe in Judds closet I
can't help but think there's some more
nefarious relationship between Senator
Kean and the Crawfords Angela fakes
being sick to gain entry into Judds room
where she takes out these nifty x-ray
glasses it's there she finds this
picture of what I think is Judd and his
father before stumbling on some Klan
robes behind his secret door Angela will
later confront will about these robes
saying that it was a setup the judge she
knows has been nothing but compassionate
there's no way he's some sort of secret
racist
we're back with Ozymandias a year after
the events in episode one judging by the
now two-year anniversary cake seen here
an anniversary for what we still don't
know I've already theorized that the
events here take place in a different
time or dimension and the evidence
supporting this continues to grow
for example Ozymandias eats a tomato off
this big tree similar to that of an
apple tree when tomatoes in our world
grow off vines it's also possible that
he had them genetically changed this
episode also draws a few comparisons
between Ozymandias and Alexander the
Great
not only is Ozzy's middle name Alexander
but his horse boo syphilis is the same
name of Alexander's horse during the
play Aussie makes reference to the
impenetrable Gordian knot which
Alexander cut loose Alexander was also
Ozymandias childhood hero so it looks
like Ozymandias says something he wants
to conquer the world time
interdimensional travel we'll need to
keep tuning in to find out Ozymandias
has finally finished his play and has
his servants perform it notice the
banner in the background which reads
Gila flats 1959 which is the time and
location when Joe Osterman became dr.
Manhattan this play is a recreation of
that event in which Ozymandias is
servant Phillips is literally killed and
replaced by someone new these servants
to the best of what we know so far are
clones of one another and Ozymandias has
apparently gone through several of them
telling the new Philips to put the body
away with the others old man Will has
somehow gotten out of his cuffs when
Angela arrives to check on him you may
have missed it but will also moves his
hands along here almost as if he's
conducting the music which ends
Ozymandias his previous scene almost
hinting at some connection between the
two after all will says if he were to
get arrested he wouldn't be held long
I've got friends in high places angela
receives a call that the DNA is eligible
for reparations and that it's connected
with her own will is her grandfather a
fact we'll already knows she decides to
arrest him and helps him into her car
when suddenly a giant magnet comes out
from out of the sky and scoops him up
leaving her with only the flyer from
1921 but who took him my best guess is
someone with a lot of money likely
Ozymandias or a much smaller chance
whoever a bien is working for who we
haven't met yet
this episode seems to have created more
questions than answers but I wouldn't
expect anything less than someone
rode on lost I hope you'll like and
subscribe and join me every week as we
break down secrets to HBO's Watchmen let
me know about what you thought about the
episode below and feel free to follow me
on twitter at things storyline team
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much